[Music]
you're in line at the grocery store when
uh-oh someone sneezes on you the cold
virus has sucked inside your lungs and
lands on a cell on your airway lining
every living thing on earth is made of
cells from the smallest one celled
bacteria to the giant blue whale to you
each cell in your body is surrounded by
a cell membrane a thick flexible layer
made of fats and proteins that surrounds
and protects the inner components it's
semi permeable meaning that it lets some
things pass in and out but blocks others
the cell membrane is covered with tiny
projections they all have functions like
helping cells adhere to their neighbors
or binding to nutrients the cell will
need animal and plant cells have cell
membranes only plant cells have a cell
wall which is made of rigid cellulose
that gives the plant structure the virus
that was sneezed into your lungs is
sneaky pretending to be a friend it
attaches to a projection on the cell
membrane and the cell brings it through
the cell membrane and inside when the
virus gets through the cell recognizes
its mistake an enemy is inside special
enzymes arrived at the scene and chopped
the virus to pieces they then send one
of the pieces back through the cell
membrane where the cell displays it to
warn neighboring cells about the invader
a nearby cell sees the warning and
immediately goes into action it needs to
make antibodies proteins that will
attack and kill the invading virus this
process starts in the nucleus the
nucleus contains our DNA the blueprint
that tells our cells how to make
everything our bodies need to function a
certain section of our DNA contains
instructions that tell ourselves how to
make antibodies enzymes in the nucleus
find the right section of DNA then
create a copy of these instructions
called messenger RNA the messenger RNA
leaves the nucleus to carry out its
orders the messenger RNA travels to a
ribosome there can be as many as 10
million ribosomes in a human cell all
studded along a ribbon-like structure
called the endoplasmic reticulum this
ribosome reads the instructions from the
nucleus it takes amino acids and links
them together one by one creating an
anti
body protein that will go fight the
virus but before it can do that the
antibody needs to leave the cell the
antibody heads to the Golgi apparatus
here it's packed up for delivery outside
the cell enclosed in a bubble made of
the same material as the cell membrane
the Golgi apparatus also gives the
antibody directions telling it how to
get to the edge of the cell when it gets
there the bubble surrounding the
antibody fuses to the cell membrane the
cell ejects the antibody and it heads
out to track down the virus the leftover
bubble will be broken down by the cells
lysosomes and it's pieces recycled over
and over again where did the cell get
the energy to do all this that's the
role of the mitochondria to make energy
the mitochondria takes oxygen this is
the only reason we breathe it and adds
electrons from the food we eat to make
water molecules that process also
creates a high energy molecule called
ATP which the cell uses to power all of
its parts plant cells make energy a
different way they have chloroplasts
that combine carbon dioxide and water
with light energy from the Sun to create
oxygen and sugar a form of chemical
energy all the parts of a cell have to
work together to keep things running
smoothly and all the cells of your body
have to work together to keep you
running smoothly that's a whole lot of
cells scientists think there are about
37 trillion of them
you
[Music]